- Hello teachers.
I'm Sal Khan, found of the
not for profit Khan Academy
and I'm here to announce a nationwide
back to school learning
challenge called LearnStorm.
LearnStorm is an exciting
way to jump start
your school year around
learning activities.
It's designed to motivate
your students and to help
build their growth mindset.
- This year was amazing with LearnStorm.
I had a group of students that couldn't
add, subtract, multiply
or divide fractions.
They avoided it at all costs.
But since it was an assignment,
they would try it and they
would eventually do much better.
And what was amazing was that
the lower achieving students
were able to see that they
were part of something huge.
They were able to contribute
and that, I thought,
boosted their self-confidence,
their self-esteem
and I didn't realize that would happen
after doing LearnStorm.
(upbeat music)
- LearnStorm is a good
way to differentiate
and as well as motivate and
with the growth mindset pieces
you can also educate them about
why it's important to
learn, how they learn,
how their body is set up to learn,
what strategies help them learn.
It's amazing, it's amazing and it's free.
(chuckling)
It's free.
- We think this is really
going to motivate your students
to understand, to
appreciate that they truly
can learn anything.
The activities have been designed to have
measurable gains in learning attitudes.
- LearnStorm made everything fun.
Like learning fun.
LearnStorm helped me
build more confidence in
believing in myself that I can do this.
I don't really think I
would go through high school
without it.
- One thing I learned from
the growth mindset activities
is that your intelligence can grow
just like your muscles grow
and that's something that
really stuck with me 'cause
I didn't know that before.
- I did over 300 lessons in one week.
I felt proud of myself
getting all these good grades.
- It helps the students tremendously.
Their confidence is higher,
they're able to do it
and it warms my heart that
they think that way now
and they know that they can keep going
and keep growing and nothing
will stand in their way.
- So together as we jump
start this school year,
I look forward for all of us
living the LearnStorm motto,
to keep going and to keep growing.
- [Students] Run deep, run
deep, run deep, run deep.